[موسيقى]
اسعدتم صباحا واهلا بكم الى صباح العربيه
الاول احلى صباح من ابرز ماسن نناقشه صباح
اليوم التاسع من يوليو
شخصيتك منذ ايام اخضت نفسي لنظريه يابانيه
حددت شخصيتي وزميلتنا لليان ستعلق بين
الارض والسماء في مغامره ما كنت شخصيا
لاجرا على القيام بها ثوره اعلاميه صغيره
ولدت في الطابق الارضي لمبنى ام بي سي
والعربيه قال اريكه جميله اردنا ان نسكن
في بيوت الناس ان يصبحوا حديثنا ونصبح
حديثنا ان يصبحوا جديدنا ونصبح جديدهم ان
نصبح القريبين وان يصبحوا الاقربين فما
الاخبار ان لم تكن من الناس ومن اجل الناس
لكن نحن كنا الرابحين ايضا اردنا ان
شاشتنا تتسع لاكثر للموسيقى والفنون
للابداع والجنون للمشاهير والمشاوير
لايف اول مره
اهلا بكم معنا في هذه الحلقه الجديده من
صباح العربيه
صباحكم سعيد من برنامج صباح العربيه يوم
جديد وحلقه جديده من صباح العربيه